hello everybody and welcome to part 16
of our intermediate Python that tutorial
series in this tutorial we're going to
continue talking about object-oriented
programming and specifically the class
that we have so far so remember those
main kind of attributes and hallmarks of
what I classified as intermediate Python
one of them was modularity the other one
was like readability and scale so with
readability I mean do we can we like
read this and see like is this gonna
work and stuff like that yeah I think so
does it scale there's really nothing in
here that's crazy
the only thing might be these lines but
we'll we will talk about those lines
shortly but the other thing is this
modularity right so with modularity
can someone easily whether it's someone
else or us take this code and quickly
make use of this code well maybe so with
blob-like one thing that's useful to do
is to take the blob class or whatever
class you're writing and put it in
another file and import it and then see
what you think so right now it's all in
this one script it's easy and things are
working it's it seems to be working just
fine we're getting some nice benefits of
object-oriented programming but what I
want us to do now is to take it and put
it somewhere so I'm going to give it a
new in fact let's just I'll just copy
this copy paste and we're gonna call
this I'm trying to think what a good
name to call it I'm gonna want to call
it blob pie it's I don't know we'll call
it blob pie I guess
let's do so with blob dot pie what we're
gonna say is we're going to take blob
pie we'll open that and blob that pie
will literally only consist of class
blob and I'm contemplating at least
giving this random let's go ahead and
give it random that seems fair enough
so we'll give it random so we'll save
that close that and I'm just gonna move
this aside now we don't need that still
and what I'm gonna change or give over
here is we're gonna get rid of the blob
class and instead let's just import it
so from blob will import blob and you
should already guessed this isn't gonna
work but let's go ahead and kind of work
through why it's not gonna work and in
fact I'm already like wondering am I did
I delete more than blob
oh okay there it is Wow I'm blind oh I
was wondering where width and height
were right there okay fantastic
let's run it see what happens okay the
first thing we get is no module No
oh I see what we've done so this was
already a PI file so so blob it needs to
be blogged up high but it is but what I
did was blob top PI to PI anyway
continuing along okay so the first thing
we get is that the error that I already
kind of alluded to and that's that width
is not defined well of course right so
so someone else was trying to use this
and in our blob class we have diff we've
basically said hey we need to use this
this width and height well that's not
accessible to anyone else right so
probably what you'd want to do is have
some sort of boundary right up here so
what we could do is maybe when we
initialize this blob we give it some
sort of range or at least require some
sort of range so we might say I'm trying
to think if I want to use something
other than width and height but I like
width and height might seem like class
blob so we could give it like we'll say
X boundary and then Y boundary okay so
now it will do is self dot X bounder
boundary equals x sound REE and then
self dot Y boundary equals y battery
okay so we'll take that and basically
replace width with X battery and height
with Y boundary
fabulous now we obviously need to come
down to where we actually call the blobs
so now you've got blob blue and we need
to also add width and height here so
blue with height and red with height
okay let's run that oh that's was that
oh we just set it on the on the the
maximums so we still need to hack cover
obviously width and height here so let's
actually cut that paste and let's do
this and this okay looking back through
here are there any no so we'll save that
and let's come back over to modularity
rerun it okay and things actually work
in this case great now closing this out
so there's a couple of things like for
example with this blob class you know
maybe X boundary my boundary you might
not even really want that you might
really think more of like like you might
not actually want the block like the
blobs map min and Max to actually be
here you might want to say like okay the
range is for the starting point or maybe
let the user say where does this blob
actually start so let the user set an
initial x and y value right so you could
do that you can also let the user decide
if they want to have this kind of
arbitrary boundary rather than you the
programmer saying yes we want to have
that now I think in the case of the blob
and in the with the understanding of
Python and pygame like you can make the
decision that you want that to be the
case like you just you just know that
because of the way PI game works there's
no like really Zoo
or anything like that so we do want the
blobs to remain on it within these
bounds also you might think about you
could like set really large default
boundaries or something so it probably
wouldn't be a problem for people but
anyway that's beside the point
um generally you'll want to keep any
kind of hard-coded values out as well so
like with self dot size you might want
to have like size range as a parameter
so you might want to throw in size range
size range and then you could set a
default if you wanted so we could say
somewhere between four and eight and
then in this case you wouldn't need to
say set a self dot side rate size range
you could just replace this and this
these zeros are acceptable that's not
really a problem and then the movement
there's a couple of things you could do
here you could set some sort of max
movement speed or maybe you could take
it upon yourself as the creator of the
blob class that nope this is as good as
it's gonna get we don't want people to
be able to move the blobs faster or
something like that so in the case of a
blob class obviously you're probably
want to give them some freedom like the
people using it but there's a lot of
other scenarios where you actually
wouldn't want to give people freedom but
at least in this case I think that you
would probably want to give people the
ability to change that so maybe give us
a movement range and then this one again
negative one to two and then we'll take
movement range and actually that need to
be equals movement range equals negative
one to two and then take this and that
should be a zero zero one
and one say that and then now someone
can just call blob and make the decision
okay do you want to pass those other
parameters or do you want to just use
the defaults and in many cases they'll
just want to see movement right oh I see
what we've done let's see at least I
think I have yeah so to access and move
here we obviously we need to set itself
down the apparent self movement range
and we'll take self dot save and that's
for that great so now anytime you know
when someone wants to use the blob class
it can be either as simple or as really
as complex as one can make a blob class
anyways because this is such a simple
thing but now we don't really have any
hard-coded things besides this zero
which maybe you might change maybe
you're gonna say boundary range like
boundary X range boundary Y range or
something like that and then you're
getting rid of these zeros and then if
you were going to do that you would for
sure get rid of these lines I'm still on
the fence as far as whether I want to
leave that in the class or not I think
it's a pretty valid thing to leave in
there but probably it would be better to
let the user do that so so for example
you might say like that and then I'm
coming over here when they run a blob
move you you might do something like
this so rather than you saying okay this
blob cannot exceed the boundaries the
user can say no this blob cannot exceed
the battery so maybe like this
is this that's gone now
oh I see okay so plump 2xy there okay so
we replace all of those and I can't
remember if we saved with this one or
not
yes so we'll run that and hopefully this
guy's gonna yeah so he seems to be
staying out so we're controlling that
now as the user of the blob class rather
than the blob class actually enforcing
this upon us and again there's going to
be times where as the the class creator
there are going to be some things that
you're going to want to enforce upon
your user and interesting that was still
there let's save that one more time
well they were like double doing that it
still appears to be working but anyway
there will be times when when you create
something you do want to force something
on a user because maybe maybe you're
trying to protect a user from Becca
violating the best practice or something
like that sometimes you want to do it
also like if you're some sort of data
analysis library and you're like a see
optimized data analysis library like
numpy or maybe your pandas and you're
using numpy and you know that you know
the best way to do something then maybe
maybe you even rather than move you
might add a method to the blob class
that checks for a boundary for exceeding
a boundaries so maybe you know the best
thing is to just do this code and so
maybe you leave that here but maybe the
method is defined check bounds cell and
then you might save that come back over
here and then instead the person if they
want to use your your method they might
say okay let's go ahead and blob dot
check bounds save make sure that one's
saved just be good to find check bounced
stuff did we forget it yeah
run it again
great I'm just waiting to make sure
nobody exceeds but anyways those are you
some some initial things to think about
we actually have a long way to go when
it comes to things you should be
thinking about when you're creating
classes and eventually I'm gonna do my
best to convince you that you probably
need to be doing something completely
different before you even write your
class entirely but we'll get there at
some point but at least for your simple
class is probably the big takeaway here
is that you'll want to think about you
don't necessarily have to I'm not a huge
proponent of taking your your your your
programs or whatever and just turning
them into these huge libraries but I am
a big fan of making sure your code can
be modular if and when possible and it's
too easy when you write it all in line
with your main whatever your main
execution is it can be too easy to do it
all together and wind up using things
like your constants and stuff like that
and not realizing that's not going to be
acceptable for either you to use the
code later on or for anyone else to use
your code and then also when you do
stuff like this just try not to try to
impose as little as possible onto
whoever your user might actually be of
the program let them make up their own
minds but you can always be you can
always do something like this where it
kind of like helps them but you probably
wouldn't want to like force them to stay
in bounds and the move the move method
but give them the option to maybe we
check boundaries or something like that
and then you could even it might even
make more sense that whether rather than
having X boundary up here you might want
to have the boundaries down here because
otherwise these are not necessary I
don't think let's see X Y and Rand range
well I guess in the end the creation of
where you want the X and y to be yeah so
I guess you would stop to have it up
there
but anyways lots of things to think
about lots of choices we could have made
on the code that's the thing with
programming I mean there probably is an
arguably best way to do it but probably
not I don't know who knows but there's a
million ways to do something but there
are certain things that you definitely
want to be thinking about as you go so
anyways that's it for this one if you
have questions comments you got better
way to you that you might think that we
should bring this blob class into being
let us know below otherwise I'll see you
all in the next tutorial